يبدو ان الجدل حول فيلم الحاره لم ينتهي
في الاردن بعد فمن وسائل التواصل الى
الشارع وصل الهجوم الى سده البرلمان في
عمان النائب الاردني سليمان ابو يحيى هاجم
الفيلم زاعما انه ينتمي الى مجموعه من
الافلام التي تسيء لسوره الاردن النائب
الاردني طالب بصحب جنسيه بطل الفيلم
الفنان منذر رياحنه مؤكدا انه اساء
للاردنيين والاردن الانا ريحنا لم يسكت عن
الامر ودافع عن الفيلم مؤكدا انه يحاكي
شريحه وفي مظلومه من الشعب الاردني على كل
حال المزيد مع صوره جميل من عمان
هل هو واقع الحال ام ضرب من خيال لا يتفق
ولا يتفق مع ذات الاردنيين ولا ما حياتهم
وربما الفاظهم ومفرداتهم من هنا بدات نقطه
الخلافه حول في الملحره احداث الفيلم تدور
في احدى حالات الاردن وتسلط الضوء على
تفاصيل حياه اهلها كجزء من المجتمع يعاني
الكثير طرح جاء من الواقع لكن المستعجنه
كان الفاظا لم تتقبلها مسامع المشاهدين من
خلال الدراما الاردني حتى لو كان في من
مجتمعنا هيك فئه المفروض يحاربوها ما
يعرضوها او يخلوها شيء طبيعي يعني انه
بحجه والله انه في من مجتمعنا ناس تحكي
بهذه الالفاظ لا من عاداتنا ولا من شيمنا
ولا من اللي علمونا يا جدودنا ولا شيء من
كل هذا الحقيقه يعني هسه لو جدي وجدك
عايشين اللي بيحضروا هيك اشياء يمكن
يذبحونه بصراحه
ما في هذه يعني في المواقع بتصور ما في
شيء
الجدل الى قبه البرلمان حيث انقسمت
المطالبات ما بين سحب الفيلم وايقاف عرضه
وصولا الى سحب الجنسيه من الفنان منذر
رياحنا لتبريره بان الفيلم رئه تعكس واقعا
حقيقيا اضافه لمطالبتهم برفع دعوه قضائيه
ضده لاساءته للهويه الاردنيه
على كلن ينضم الى الفنان منذر رياحنه ومن
عمان النائب سالم العمري اهلا بكم يسعد
صباحكم اشكرك على وجودكم معنا يسعد صباحك
مره جديده في صباح العربيه شكرا على
تواجدك معانا من جديد يا منذر لتوضيح كل
شيء اهلا بك
اهلا وسهلا
الفيلم وصل الى قبه البرلمان دعوه لسحب
جنسيتك من من النائب بتهمه الاساءه للاردن
كيف ترد على هذه الدعوه
يعني اول شيء صباح الخير يعني اذا بطلع
معاكوا المره الثالثه لازم اخذ جائز يعني
[موسيقى]
الله يحميكم يا رب والله يا صديقتي
اظن في عنا اشياء ااا
ومهام للنواب كبيره جدا اطول من من هذا
اللي بصير ولكن بالنسبه لاخر الاشياء اللي
صارت همم راح ننتظر القانون والقضاء
الاردني لانه اظن صار في همم في لقطه كبير
يعني وصار في اساءه بشكل شخص
طيب خليني يا منذر اروح لاستاذ سالم سالم
اليوم عندما نسمع المطالبات بسحب الجنسيه
للفنان منذر رياحنه من داخل قبه البرلمان
مجلس النواب الاردني خلصت مشاكل الدنيا هل
اليوم كل واحد مش عاجبه شو بيعمل الاخر
نطالب بسحب الجنسيه يعني لا مطلب قانوني
ولا مطلب دستوري اريد ان اسمع تعليقك اولا
صباح الخير ويعطيكم العافيه ويشرفنا انظم
معكم اليوم سلام الى جميع المشاهدين بدايه
اهلا فيك بدايه همم سته البرلمان الاردني
هذا سقف الكلام في مرفوع وزي ما بده
الواحد بيحكي بعبر عن الراي اللي بيحتاجه
بيعبر عن الفكره اللي بده يحكي فيها ما في
مشكله بموضوع شو طرح الزميل وشو طلبات
الزميل وايجابي على موضوع انه خلصت
المشاكل كلها بس احنا ما ضل عندنا غير هذه
المشكله
اختي العزيزه في احنا عندنا في مجلس
النواب لجنه اسمها لجنه التوجيه الوطني
والاعلام والثقافي هذه اللجنه تعني
وتتابع جميع ما
يتعلق بموضوع الاعلام وموضوع الثقافي
وموضوع
النشر داخل المملكه وانا احد اعضاءها فهذا
شيء طبيعي انه يكون طبيعي انه متابعه منه
طبيعي يشوف احنا ما يتم توجيهه ل- اا
مواطننا ولا جميعا اللي موجودين في البلد
من صميم شغلنا ومن عملنا احد اللجان
الموجوده كما يوجد لجن ماليه كما يوجد
لجنه همم سياحيه كما يوجد لجنه نقل لجنه
امراه عده لجان فهي احد اللجان التي تعني
بهذا الامر وهذا الشان طيب من هذا جواب
لهذا الموضوع منذ نحاول يعني نشوف ليش
الجدل هذا ونقول لك الصوره وانت من حقك
ترد وتبرع طيب منذر بعض يقول انه نقل
معاناه الشعب الاردني ليس بالضروره ان
يكون بوضع الشتائم والفاظنا بيه في الفيلم
كيف ترد يعني يعتبر
هذا السؤال موجه لي طبعا يا منذر
والله والله يا ستي اول شيء انا بدي بس
اتاكد لاني مش شايف انت في السيد سالم
العمري هو اللي طلع معاي في احد القنوات
الفضائيه الاردنيه سلمى عمر السيد النائب
سلمى العمري
[موسيقى]
اكثر من مره بانه احنا اخذنا شريحه من
المجتمع وقدمناها كما هي اه الان بحكي لك
انه الفن مراه المجتمع او شيء واقع او كذا
هذا الشيء موجود
والكل يعترف فيه يعني انا اخر تعليق سمعته
كثير حلو من بنت
فيلم رعب وجبنا فيه اشباح راح يطلعوا
يحكوا فش اشباح عنا يعني انا مش فاهم اللي
صار زائد انا ما بحبش حد يزاود علي يعني
اظن في حكايه موجوده همم
يعني السيد سالم
يعني من حقنا اننا نعمل سبوت لايت عليها
اييه من حقنا ان نقدمها اييه هذه البيئه
التي ظلمت اه
فانتجتها هكذا اشخاص زائد انا بحكي للمره
المليون هذا المثل هذا الفيلم لا يمثل
عاداتنا ولا تقاليدنا ولا كل هذه التفاصيل
هذا بيمثل شريحه من المجتمع من المجتمع
صار عليها كل هذا الظلم نتيجه هذا الظلم
تم وجود هذول الاشخاص زائد زي ما احنا
صغار بنحكي بيحكي لك كل اللي بيكذب الله
بحطه بالنار هذا الزلمه كان في عنده
مجموعه من الالفاظ السيئه انقطع لسانه
ووصل لمرحله الموت او القتل باي شكل من
الاشكال انت لازم تقدم الشخصيه
ونشوف نتائجها او نتيجه افعلها قدام
الشاشه قدام الشاشه سينما شاشه سينما
يعني استاذ سالم انا لاحظت في الاونه
الاخيره كل ما يطلع عمل فيلم مسلسل اردني
مؤخرا وتخرج الاصوات لا يمثلنا ولا يمثلنا
يعني اريد ان اسمع اين هي هذه المدينه
الفاضله التي لا يوجد فيها اشخاص يتلفضون
بعبارات سيئه يرتكبون افعالا مسيئه او
ربما حتى جرائم
تمام سيدتي انا بقول انا معك ومعي الاستاذ
منذر بهذا الموضوع احنا بنحكي هاي الطبقه
موجوده صحيح انا لا انكر وهذه الالفاظ
موجوده بالمجتمع لا يمكن انا عندي ان
كارلا شغله واحده انكار اربط هذا الاسم
بالحاره لا باعطيه اسم ثاني للفيلم بعطيه
العصابه بعطيه قصه حياتي بعطي الاشرار طب
كيف يعني انا ربطت اسم الحاره الاردنيه
بهذا الجزئيه منها الناس بعدين في عندي
شغله ال- ال- الشريحه التي ظلمت انا يعني
من الناس اتفرجت على الفلوس شفته ما فهمت
انا الظلم الظلم لانه مثلا مش متعلمين دول
لانه في فقر وين الظنون كان يعني
فرجانا وين الظلم بهذا المجتمع عرفتي وين
المؤاخذه المؤاخذه الفكره انه ليش اربطها
باسم الحاره على عيني
وانا ما بانكرها وبنتعامل فيها مش سميته
الفيلم الحاره
عشان احنا بنحا الحاره
اردنيه
ظهر في بدايه المسلسل صدرك جلاله الملك
طيب
في مشاكل في البرنامج العنوان هو المشكله
ما في مشاكل لانه احنا العنوان المشكله
العنوان انا بقول قصه حياتي حياتي همم
عصابه اشرار اي اسم بس مش هاي الحاره اللي
نحكي عنها لانه في 100 جانبه
وهذا موجود من الحاره اللي بحكي عن
الاستاذ بس في جوال اخرى يا اخي اظهر كامل
استاذ سالم
[موسيقى]
اظهرنا هذه البنت التي حبت
وحاربت تشهد والتشهد في النهائي لتبني
مكان غير مكانها يا صديقي اه
يعني شفنا الصديق اللي حاول قدر الامكان
يبعد الصوره السيئه عن صديقه اللي مات
قدام اهله ورجعنا كلها الاشياء شفنا الام
هاي ال ال ال ال ال اللي صار عليها الضغط
في لحظه من اللحظات زائد انك كمان تعال
بدي احكي لك عن عباس وهو شخصيه موجوده بكل
الحارات الاردنيه اللي بيدير باله على
الحاره واللي ممنوع حد يدخل وممنوع حد
يروح ويجيء موجود الشخص اللي بروح على همم
مجموعه من الاماكن وبياخذ منهم فلوس مقابل
حمايه هذه الاماكن ايفر نفسه هي موجوده
موجوده يا صديقي
بتكون ما بين الخير والشر نعم
حاره معينه في الاردن لكن بدايه الفيلم
يعني لم يقل مثلا هذا الفيلم واستوحه من
احداث حقيقيه وان لم تكن هذه الاحداث تمثل
الواقع 100% ولكنها يعني فيها نوع من
الخيال نوع من الحبكه من القصه المرتبطه
بفيلم وهنا تاتي حريه التعبير والفن
والابداع
انا مع حريه الفن والتعبير انا قلت لك انا
ما اخذتي ارتباط وباسم الحاره بدايته زائد
انا ما ظهرت الي بالنسبه الي كمشاهد وين
الحبكه بالفيلم يعني
اتصورت انه احنا عايشين بعدنا بمكان لا
يوجد في امن وامان لا يوجد فيه اي قوات
امنيه عدم وجود حسيت حالي بمكان معزول
حسيت كانه هالحرم صور عليها ومحكوم لشخص
معين همم بيقول الاستاذ منذر انه هذه ال
ال موجود هذا عباس بكل حاره اردنيه انا ما
بعرف ما شفته انا انا من الناس اللي ولدت
باحد هذه الحارات يعني انا همم ولدت في
منطقه تسمى جبل التاج في عمان من الحراره
تعتبر عمان الشرقيه تعتبر مجاوره للحالات
التي تم فيها تصوير هذا الفيلم ما كنت
اشاهد انه في واحد مسيطر على الحاره
السيطره كنت اشوف انه دائما من من
السبعينات والامن موجود ومن السبعينات
ملجانا كان الامن العام والشرطه
والمرتبات الامنيه يعني استغربت لجوء يعني
الام لجوءها لشخص ازعر مشان ينهي جدل
بنتها واحنا عارفين عنا مليون مسرب
ومسربوا وتشريعات جديده قويه وتشريعات
وجدت بالاون الاخيره بالسنين الاخيره تحمي
هذا الامر كله فيعني ما عرفت وين الحبكه
ما عرفت وين القصه حتى الان ما عرفت وين
الظنون مصاب
تفضل
سيد سالم
[موسيقى]
هذا رقم واحد رقم اثنين لا موجود موجود
سيد سالم وموجود بانه همم
الام تلجا اه واحنا عارفين في عنا شيء في
المجتمع همم خوفا من الفضيحه وخوفا اني
اروح الامن والبروسيس اللي موجود ولكن
موجود في طبقه معينه وعارفين في طبقه
معينه انهم بيلزقوا الواحد اللي بالحاره
عشان يعالج الموضوع
تصورت بنتها فراحت عند واحد بيقدر يتعامل
مع الزهره
الان بتعمل 3000 مسلسل عن الحاره يا صديقي
7000 مسلسل بتعملوا على الحاره
والان في عندنا ثور نطور فيلم الحاره الى
مسلسل ثمن حلقات راح تشوف فيه حوادث عباس
لحاله حدوته لحاله
والشخصيات كل شخصيه اذا بدك تاخذها تقدر
تعمل عنها مسلسل احنا اخذنا هذا الباب
وهذا الجزئيه وشفنا النهايه النهايه اصرار
البنت على الحياه وانها راحت وبنت مكان
ثاني
نعم ولكن
نريد ان نشير رغم كل الجدل الحاصل حول
فيلم الحاره الا انه لا يمكن ان ننكر بان
الامن مستتب ومستقر في الاردن الاكثر
البلاد المستقره امنيا شكرا جزيلا لكم
الفنا المندياحنا اكيد ومن عمان النائب
سالم العمري شكرا لكم